Hello, Andrea, how are you?
Hello, I am fine. How are you today?
I'm doing good. So how's your Monday?
Oh, that's good.
It's good so far.
And you'll begin.
Oh, it was very nice. The weather's finally turning, so that always puts me in a good mood.
Yeah, but here it's too hot when we are in extreme summers.
Oh, is it like 90?
Oh.
So it's really hot.
We've got 60 degrees Fahrenheit and I'm thrilled because it's been so cold.
Singh.
In Delhi, I mean, where we are right now, it's around 102.
Oh my gosh, even for me, who likes hot weather, that's a little much.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's too hot.
Do you have humidity there?
No, not yet. Humidity, the months for humidity are August and September.
Oh.
Okay.
So right now it's dry heat completely.
Well, that's a little bit easier to manage.
Yeah, yeah, a little bit easier. Immunity is very difficult to manage.
Yeah.
Right, even if it's like 65 and humid, it can be difficult.
Alright, so how are things going?
Um, things are going well.
About the same, which I guess is good. No news is good news.
Is Chris also going to join this call or he's busy?
I haven't heard otherwise, so why don't we wait and find out?
Yeah.
How's Ashish these days? I haven't heard from him in a while.
He's doing well, yeah, he's doing great.
Uh-huh, good.
I will ask him to join.
The call someday.
Okay.
Just to say hello to you and Chris.
Yes, yes.
So, so, how is Simrin doing any feedback, anything you have noticed, any areas of improvement?
Um...
She, she is doing a very good job.
I haven't seen anything to complain about. She's really doing a great job.
She's very responsive when I ask her to do something. She always gets it done in a timely manner.
Yeah.
That's great.
What was that? Was that an AI thing?
Yeah, note taker from some of the from someone from the CX team, customer experience team.
Yeah.
Ohh.
Okay.
Should we wait for Prince or shall we start? What do you say?
Um, why don't we start? Why don't we start?
Okay, okay. Yeah, let me share my screen real quick.
Sure.
Are you able to see my screen?
Yes, thank you.
Okay, great. So once again, welcome to our bi-weekly business review. And this is for the last two weeks, starting April 13th till April 24th.
Agenda would be the same, no change. Started with check-in, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of your customer, pay forward, and recap.
And we already talked about how things are going right now. So thank you for sharing your feedback for summary.
Sure.
So again, in the highlights, we have been getting good feedback for Sandrine. She's capable, pleasant, and reliable. Appreciation for strong ticket notes and documentation. We also talked about Sandrine to reach out to Chris sooner whenever she's stuck.
That is happening. That is very good.
On it, yep, yep, and regarding the KPI reporting set up in Autotac, that is in progress. I've opened a ticket with Kaseya and I'm working with them, so we'll soon share the progress on that with Chris.
Okay.
And yeah, this is a KP expectation. This is what we are working with Kaseya right now. And regarding the CSAT survey for some rain for the month of March that has already been sent. So whenever you get a time to check with Chris, just ask him to.
OK.
take out some time and fill out that survey for her.
Moving on to the action tracker, again, we are working on, we are working with Caseya on building the reports. That is in progress. And level up for Sumreen to advance system administrator, that is also in progress. We expect her to finish her level up by the end of May.
Mmh.
These are the KPIs which we recommend and we can skip this. Let's jump into the performance for some rain for the last two weeks. So this is our utilization for the last two weeks.
Okay.
Solpro.
I'm surprised it's a little bit low because she seems to be very busy and working often, so I would expect it to be higher than it is.
Yeah.
So maybe the communication that happens over the teams or over the calls, maybe she's not able to track those.
Right, right.
But yeah, that could be the reason.
Yeah, because I don't see her wasting any time, which is great. And when she needs something to do, which is not very often, but when she does, she asks me, and I'm happy to provide it for her.
Yeah.
Yeah, and for...
But if we do have a problem with calling people and leaving a voicemail and then they don't get back to us and we have to email them. So I know that that does drag tickets down.
Yeah.
Yeah, right.
So, we'll see how this goes.
So her average utilization for those two weeks had been 57%. This first week was 59 and 54. A couple of tickets were on our waiting user, so.
Yeah.
And moving on to the ticket data, that is also a little bit aligned with her utilization. She worked on 82 tickets in total and closed 38. So in the first week, April 13th till 17th, she worked on 42 tickets and closed 16.
Okay.
And in the week after, she worked on 40 tickets and closed 22.
So her ticket closure for the last two weeks had been 47% on an average.
And way forward.
We want somebody to proactively reach out as soon as she needs help on any issue. And we'll continue to support her to close more tickets.
And this is the the Build ITBD Live 26th. That is an event happening on in August from 3rd till 5th. I will.
Why are they scheduling it at that time of year? That's like the hottest time of the year in New Jersey.
I used to live in New Jersey and like, that's like when everybody leaves. No, I'm serious. I mean, that's like, it's a really hot week. Who decided on that one?
Yeah.
Yeah, I understand, dude.
Ha.
So, no problem. Um, I will share these details with Chris, and uh, will take.
Sure.
And this is the AI by design. Again, something you already aware and Chris too. And this is the Team GPS.
We can skip this and that's it. Any question, anything you want to share, suggest?
Okay.
I think we covered it.
Okay, great. So again, you don't have to wait for these calls to happen. You can always reach out to me whenever you have anything to share. So, yeah. And we will meet next on.
OK.
I will.
Is that the 11th?
Our next call is scheduled on 11th, yes.
Okay, I want to let you know to change the calendar. We have a call scheduled for the 25th, but that's a U.S. holiday, so none of us are working that day. So if you could move that to the 26th.
Yeah, we can, yeah, we can move that, we can skip that. I mean, so that is, we will discuss that on 11th.
Okay.
For sure. Yeah, no problem.
Okay, thank you, Andrea, for joining this call and sharing the feedback. And yeah, have a wonderful rest of the day and week.
Okay. Okay.
Okay, thank you. Have a good week.
Yeah, you too. Bye.
Okay, bye.